people were surprised by the following
that I didn't have government I didn't
have a man having project as the star of
the show for how we're going to adapt to
climate change my hero was was Adam
Smith's hero it was capitalism as the
star of the show I said you see ladies
Institute the environment but at the end
of the day these are social science
questions so I have many colleagues at
UCLA's Institute of the environment who
asked me if everyone in the world
achieves the American dream
if all seven billion of us have a house
have a car no pollution just go to hell
and they're shocked when I tell them no
the economic growth will actually help
us to achieve the win winning of
reducing poverty and improved
environmental quality of life and so I
am NOT a climate change denier I believe
what my climate scientist colleagues at
UCLA are setting that the challenge of
climate change is real and is
approaching but where I differ from my
colleagues is my belief based on
microeconomics that we will be able to
adapt to many of the challenges of
climate change because of cat free
market capitalism and so I've written
the book climate appleís which has made
everyone nuts that but it hasn't helped
with book sales environmentalists are
shocked that there's environmentalist in
me who believes that free market
capitalism will help us to adapt to the
challenge of climate change free market
capitalism by giving us the income and
wealth that capitalism produces has
scaled up it has increased greenhouse
gas emissions but the same free market
capitalism will help us to attend to
many of the challenges that climate
change will pose economic growth
involves both quantity and quality so as
we get richer we do consume more stuff
we drive more we consume more
electricity but there's also a quality
effect that many environmentalists tend
to ignore that as we grow richer we
demand quality of life and we want we
want more safety and capitalism is is an
amazingly adaptable system that when
there's the
and supply will subsequently follow and
so an example I've done some work on the
death toll from natural disasters when
when natural disasters like floods and
earthquakes occur hurricanes
it's horrible that there's death from
these natural disasters but Richard
nation suffered less death from the same
blows it mother nature poses because
Richard people live in higher quality
housing have access to better food and
better health care and so income helps
to shield us from Mother Nature I think
this theme is very relevant for thinking
about adapting to climate change Richard
cities will adjust pretty well to
climate change but what will happen to
Bangladesh what will happen to Africa
cities the challenge of climate change
makes it imperative that there be even
more economic development in Africa
because with income growth you have more
coping strategies for the challenges
were likely to face we have many coastal
seas with New Orleans with Hurricane
Katrina horrible stuff in 2005 we never
would anticipate that we're going to
face more severe hurricanes in the
future are we passive victims here and
allow mother nature to punch us in the
chin no what we're seeing entrepreneurs
doing right now and grandpa is working
with some at UCLA is designing floatable
homes so we anticipate a challenge more
urban flooding and we are making choices
at several levels how we design our
future homes floatable home is is an
interesting concept and just one idea
but there's many other subtle heroes
here the insurance industry racing
insurance premium and risky areas
sending price signals to households to
of where to live and what materials to
live in if they're in a fire zone or in
a flood zone so the insurance industry
don't it's going to make a movie out of
course not gonna make a movie about the
insurance industry yeah I knew that is a
player in sending a signals of the new
risks that Mother Nature will pose to us
it's not a government employee giving up
orders and don't live here don't live
there it's the price system sending
signals and this is the rise of
environment
entrepreneurs it's not
government-mandated it's not at some
top-down system with some five years
Soviet or Chinese plan they serve
individual entrepreneurs experimenting
and tinkering and aid I don't need a
hundred percent of America and become
environmental entrepreneurs but I
predict that if two percent of our
population have this entrepreneurial
streak they will try some will fail but
those who succeed will be our next
Zuckerberg and we collectively will be
grateful to these guys it's important to
think through unintended consequences of
well-meaning government actions so the
government builds sea walls or promises
to rebuild communities that are flooded
is simple economics predicts that more
people will locate in those dangerous
areas and so this is a classic crowding
out case if Milton Friedman were
president and if he said I'm gonna be
tough love and I'm not gonna rebuild I'm
not gonna bail out anyone who's in a who
is exposed to a natural disaster people
would have to sell protect and take
actions to protect their own families
and while that tough love approach might
appear to be cruel you would have the
direct effect that we have fewer victims
because you wouldn't have the strategic
game between people and their government
the proper role for government in
adapting to climate change is providing
high quality information is the
equivalent of tsunami alerts so that we
know the threats we face it's common
knowledge what challenges climate change
will pose and then allow individuals and
firms to create with each other and
effect to help individuals make
decisions that they don't regret but
then to have some faith in individual
rationality and the profit motive for
firms to seek out solutions to these
challenges we will face there are
collective solutions so for example I'm
a big fan of the nature conservancy so
so there's environmental clubs that
collect donations from green minded
successful people and use these to buy
Atlantis private property and such
carbon sequestration by protecting trees
is a fun way to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions the incentives I want to see
to help
to adapt to climate change is to allow
free markets to work right now we don't
have a free market for water pricing or
electricity pricing I want these prices
low to reflect supply and demand and as
resources get scarce to expose consumers
to rising prices for scarce goods you
can't make a great bumper sticker for
this maybe reason TV could but my one
sexy bumper sticker for adapting to
climate change this view from the
markets a chance